what's up
guys bang bang lunch money
time well while she's trying to get rich
for us let's just try to get her lunch
money right
i'm here with paulina she's got a sheep
jacket on looking great as always don't
forget lunch money is now sponsored by
block five block five has three products
you can buy and sell crypto you can use
a crypto deposit to take out a us dollar
loan against your crypto collateral
or you can use my favorite product i'm
an investor in the company i sit on the
board
and i use the product i got paid
yesterday yup
me i got paid interest on my bitcoin
because i use their interest bearing
account isn't it we got paid yesterday
we we kidding
are you done are you done she's not
kidding don't forget that blockfi
can pay up to 8.6 apy in the interest
bearing account that we
use go ahead and you can sign up at
blackfy.com
pomp again blackflight.com pomp what's
up does my ear look like an elf again
okay um non-farm pay what are you
looking for somebody's calling me go
ahead
non-farm payrolls rose by a lower than
expected 661
000 in september and the unemployment
rate was 7.9 percent the labor
department said friday
wow so non-farm payrolls is like
basically
jobs that are non-farm look there we go
i don't know
why we have to separate it but okay all
right so 7.9 unemployment
they are so jobs go ahead jobs are being
added right
well they're claiming that there's
monthly job growth
uh about 661 000.
my guess is that this 7.9 percent
uh is still being manipulated
low in terms of how they're officially
counting the numbers uh
i my guess is that we're on an
unofficial standpoint up over 10 percent
unemployment still uh but we'll see it
says we're losing momentum
in terms of adding jobs every month it
was lower this month
than it was in august well it's 7.9 i
think
if you don't include the farm and then
if you include that it's 8.2 percent
in september yeah because 8.2 percent i
think it's the official number that
they're calling right
well the decline in the unemployment
rate came along with a 0.3 percentage
point drop in the labor force
participation rate to 61.4 percent
all right well i things aren't looking
great
what's the bottom line people are going
back to work slowly but surely
the house passed a 2.2 trillion dollar
democratic
coronavirus stimulus plan on thursday
night even as democrats in the trump
administration
struggled to strike a relief deal so
this means that if the house passed it
and the senate passed it
it's going to get passed why are you not
talking
i know you don't want me to talk about
it but we got to talk about it what
trump got the virus well that was gonna
be my joke
well not like a joke but you'll see
you'll see you'll see it's not a joke
trump got the virus
that also means that now the stimulus
package deal
takes on a whole new level of gravity
because you basically have a president
who's got to go into quarantine
there's like 35 days i think until uh or
33 days or something like that 35 days
until the election so it changes the way
that the campaign is done
it changes all sorts of things around
the negotiation of the stimulus package
um and right now the democratic bill
includes
reinstating the 600 per week of enhanced
unemployment
they send a second 1200 direct payment
to most americans 436 billion in relief
over one year to state and local
governments
they authorize more money for a second
round of ppp they give 25 billion
dollars to airlines to cover payroll
costs they inject 75 billion into co-bid
testing
225 billion into education 57 billion
into child care and they set aside
billions for rental and mortgage
assistance
this is insane is is the president
allowed to work
during quarantine yeah of course oh
really yeah you got a cell phone
you got a phone you got your computer
yeah but like you're supposed to be
resting
wow quarantine is you got to stay away
from people
if he gets if he has symptoms i i don't
think we know yet he said he has
mild symptoms okay so he is symptomatic
then
if it gets bad yeah he's gonna have to
like do it i mean look this is this is
serious as much as we joke around here
this is very serious in the sense of
you've got a president who's 74 75 years
old uh
he is by the kind of official standards
he's obese
right and uh i'm not sure what sort of
underlying health conditions he has but
if he has any
uh it's just kind of this is the exact
demographic that
uh this virus is absolutely you know
wrecked and
yeah and so it's very sad uh you always
want to make sure that everyone
you know is safe um it's not just him
it's his wife it's other people in the
white house
right yeah so it's just it's just a bad
situation but i do think it puts
a much bigger degree of severity and
kind of spotlight on the stimulus
package
as you saw there's billions and billions
of dollars going to covet 19 testing
all that kind of stuff so it wouldn't
surprise me if there's some last second
changes
uh to some of the bill um just because
it's kind of the gravity of the
situation i saw
uh you know blake robbins uh i know
shout out blake i
definitely watch this but but if blake
watched this um
blake is uh he works at ludlow ventures
and uh
one of the smarter guys when it comes to
thinking about like social and creator
economy and things like that
but he tweeted in uh last night he was
basically like this
has the feel of the gravity of the night
when remember when tom hanks
uh got it and also the nba shut down
yeah right
like same thing right it's like the
president of the united states has it
so it's kind of just like i think it you
know just shocks the system a little bit
and everyone
um obviously talking about covert more
also provides more uncertainty in the
markets
and therefore you get more volatility in
the markets and so the stimulus package
almost becomes more necessary um
but but my question is can he pass it in
quarantine
can he be like yeah signing off
technically he doesn't pass it
the house and the senate pass it but he
has to signs off
right i mean you could sign it wherever
i don't do you think that they would put
the paper under the door no i'm sorry
i'm saying can he kill it well i mean
everything's still the same right he's
still the president he still
has all the same powers so i'm just
saying he could veto it i guess if he
wanted to
okay google will pay publishers more
than one billion dollars over the next
three years through a new program for
licensing news
the tech giant has signed licensing
deals with about 200 publications and
select countries with plans to add more
and expand geographically
oh interesting because shrinking ad
revenue is suddenly taking a toll on a
lot of newsrooms
and diminishing resources for telling
local stories so
this billion dollar spend maybe will
beef up some newsrooms
i don't think this is sustainable this
is what we call
slippery slope my friends that's exactly
what facebook did
facebook paid publishers to come on the
platform and they slowly took away their
distribution after they built their
businesses on facebook uh
also don't be surprised if google has a
similar feed also it's a little bit of a
conflict right in my
eyes like if you're a reporter covering
big tech google's paying your bills
like wow yeah i mean for the small group
of people who do
tech coverage yes i guess for everybody
else
all right all right what's next
roadblocks continue
roblox's yes do i know what roblox is
it's a gaming platform it's working with
billions of dollars
investment banks to prepare for a u.s
stock market listing that could come
early next year
the gaming platform expects it could
double its recent four billion dollar
valuation it's gonna go public via
spec no traditional ipo or a direct
listing
got it uh i'm shocked that they're
saying that this cup is only worth 8
billion
no that it could so it's most recently
valued at 4 billion
but they're saying it could be valued at
double i think it's worth way more than
that
really yeah from what i've read uh i'm
was shocked that it was below 10 billion
evaluation but we'll see what happens
hey guys hold on a second before uh
before we go anywhere my brother's here
look he's running away
like he he was literally just running
away because he doesn't want to be on
camera
and now he's giggling as you that as he
goes down the stairs like oh it's okay
they look the same
yeah he's a loser all right actually
speaking of gaming he's awesome
speaking of but he's still a loser
running away sorry he's a loser
he's like a lovable loser like i love
him but he's a loser you know
speaking of gaming david beckham is
taking his
esports company public in a london ipo
did you know david beckham co-founded a
gaming company called
guild esports a uk based owner and
developer of esports teams
i mean that's pretty cool it will float
40 of its shares next month and hopes to
raise 25.9 million dollars to recruit
new players and invest in the business
esports is going to take off well it's
already taken off i'll mark my words
yeah but i feel should we start esports
team what are we going to play
chess you're definitely not going to
play chess so we want to win we don't
want to
do it for entertainment purposes
david baker david beckham good job
okay all right what's next okay
it's not my fault you're not good at
chat you know how you i've beaten you
the last five
games we played are you gonna lie on i
was drunk three of the times
i literally my eyes were i was like
falling asleep and we're playing chess
and she beats me
check mated him in like three moves
that's definitely nice okay
you know how like you said malls are
gonna shut down permanently i never said
oh did you say that there would be mega
malls somebody i didn't say that either
there's a three million dollar square
foot no you did say that you were like
there's gonna be a mega mall in all
these little shops
i don't know three million dollar square
oh
3 million square foot american dream
mega mall is reopening
a long-awaited massive american dream
mall was just about to fully open when
the pandemic hit
forcing its doors shut but as of
thursday it's open for business
it's in east rutherford new jersey 300
oh sorry 3 million square feet it's
massive what do you think
there's an indoor people still need to
shop they're still going to go to the
mall
i mean look if they have an auntie
anne's is a good mall if they don't have
auntie anne's is it bad that's a theme
park
oh it's got theme it definitely has
auntie they're selling a lot of pretzels
indoor ski slope opening during the
winter
now i won't be going on that they have a
ski slope they better have the pretzels
it has
40 water slides with the water park
roller coasters
rides they got pretzels for sure all
right auntie anne's is the best place at
the mall everybody knows that
it doesn't say auntie anne's is the best
place at the mall
if you disagree i don't care you're
wrong guys the other day he made me take
the subway for the first time just so he
could get an auntie anne's in the subway
pla subway system hey you just know you
just
you just sniff it you just smell it it's
like we did today's lunch
is very fast there is crack can i
read you my joke what you got when trump
was asked if he handled
kobit properly he responded i'm positive
it's a little bit of a pun it's a little
bit of a pun
it's a good one we were doing jokes not
puns
pun is a joke sorry you got lucky on
that joke
um guys if you are on youtube and you're
watching this video and you really like
it make sure you like it
and comment and subscribe but also go to
my channel paulina marinova
and you can see my interviews on there
like comment subscribe review
call your mom make her subscribe review
are you
are you promoting your own youtube
channel oh am i not allowed
no you can the profile you're lucky had
a shirt on i thought you were about to
do that with no shirt off all right guys
that's it for lunch money
we'll talk to you guys on monday
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block fly's my second favorite thing in
the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6 percent interest on
an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends